in recent days we've seen a number of
women over the age of 60 exercise new
power and prestige and we are Santa
hallelujah as a New York Times headline
puts it I'm an older woman hear me roar
some examples include Nancy Pelosi who
at age 78 was re-elected Speaker of the
House Glenn Close who won the Golden
Globe for Best Actress at 71 and here at
CBS News our incoming president is 66
year-old Susan Zorinsky but not all
older workers are seeing success in the
latter years of life a new study claims
about 56 percent of workers over the age
50 have faced or could face what's
called employer driven job loss now
that's according to a recent analysis by
Pro Publica and the Urban Institute last
year two longtime ohio state university
teachers reached a settlement after
suing over age discrimination the women
claimed one supervisor even told called
them Deadwood it was kind of shocking to
be referred to so negatively it's just a
real slap in the face there's at no
question in our minds or in our lawyers
minds or in the minds of the EEOC that
these were actions related to age in our
work in progress series we've partnered
with LinkedIn to take a closer look at
issues affecting the workforce LinkedIn
editor-in-chief Dan Roth is here with
how older employees can protect their
jobs welcome back thanks for having me
so in one economist in the Pro Publica
story said working after 50 is
considerably riskier and more turbulent
than we previously thought didn't we
already think it was pretty tough we
knew was tough we didn't realize it was
this tough when you have the majority of
workers over 50 who will lose their job
at least once and only 10% will be able
to get a job that earns as much if they
get a job again those are terrifying
numbers it means the majority of us are
gonna be hit by this at some point in
our lives this will affect everyone and
the study shows that it doesn't matter
your income your age what geography
you're in what industry you're in it
affects everyone why don't they like us
Dan doesn't experience and wisdom count
for anything absolutely but the problem
tell me why they
like us I think that the the issues are
income older workers are more you've
been around for longer you've gotten
those raises but you don't listen the
company's having some trouble can we
reduce your salary yeah but they don't
maybe having that option they don't do
that companies just that it's not part
of the game plan the companies have in
their playbook
there's also tight however don't want
anyone to say that to me things they're
like technological or do they have the
right skills maybe there is there's a
bias to saying the younger workers
understand technology better there is
competition global competition you have
new industries that are challenging
companies that have never been
challenged before and they're saying we
need people who are younger more vibrant
who can be more adaptable and these
older workers don't get it or their I
don't want to manage them and then the
last part is that Millennials are now
the majority in the workplace and you
know the the when you work at a company
it's a pyramid you have to climb your
way to the top and in order to give
promotions and raises to people it means
you've got to clear some room at the top
those are older workers so there's a lot
of things that are stacked the deck is
stacked against older okay but what are
some of the benefits that older workers
bring don't workplace there are so many
it is a no-brainer to have older workers
in your workplace they're happier at
work they take fewer sick days they have
experience they're better a problem
solving I mean the list goes on and on
and for a company that's thinking long
term and how to make sure that you have
that you're competitive you should have
more older workers in your workplace
that will do you that would be a huge
benefit to you other than handing the
list you just made to your boss what can
an older worker do to protect them yeah
number one is you got to keep your
skills up to date you have to constantly
be training and I don't think this is
true just of older workers if I were in
my thirties forties you have to start
getting those skills now because you
don't want to just suddenly start
playing catch-up but you have to
continuously be learning the second
thing is that I would keep a job on the
side you want to have a side hustle
going on because the truth is that if
the if you have a high likelihood of
being pushed out which all of us do and
every one of your people watching the
show do then you want to make sure
there's something you can fall back on
even if you don't earn as much you want
to be your own boss
alright someone wrote me and said what
companies will outsource wisdom but they
won't hire for it so you want to be a
consultant make sure you can be in
control of your own destiny got to come
up with a side hustle how old man I'm 45
so they say you got time
thank you thank you